Would you like to do a potato chip tasting with me?
Sure, I would.
I want you to know that my dog already started
and ate two bowls of potato chips without me.
Oh my god, I love it.
Well, I'd love to get your dog's opinion.
All right.
Which one do you wanna start with, Bridget?
You lead the...
Direct.
Let's start with the one on your right, so that should be,
what is that?
Is it the rotisserie chicken?
Uh-huh.
Oh my god.
(audience laughs)
Mm.
This is the one my dog liked, by the way.
(audience laughs)
That makes a-
I'm just wondering, could we get rotisserie chicken
with like green beans
and maybe a salad mixed in there,
so I just have to eat the chips and not the whole meal.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, like a-
You know what I mean?
A TV dinner chip.
(audience laughs)
I love TV dinners.
I do too.
This is weird, I'm not gonna lie.
What do you think, Bridget, yay or nay?
Mm, it's a little much for me.
Okay, next.
This one scares me.
It's called salted egg.
It's what comes out of the chicken.
(audience laughs)
I don't know if I needed that visual
as I'm putting it in my mouth.
Mm-mm.
Tastes like hay.
(audience laughs)
Or like the shavings that you put in the chicken coop.
Yeah, thank you, no. Mm-mm.
All right, next, Bridget.
I'm not going with that one.
Uh-uh.
Yeah.
Then next up is the...
(Bridget laughs)
I'm actually excited for this one.
It sounds normal, ketchup.
Oh my god.
So...
I'm kind of like the Forrest Gump
when it comes to potatoes and tomatoes,
I will eat them any which way, boiled, fried, pureed.
But I don't like ketchup.
You know, I'm not a big ketchup person either,
I prefer mustard.
But I got to give it up, if you like ketchup,
you got to get these chips.
I'll find out who made them
because they are ketchup in a chip.
I mean, whoa!
Whoever was in the lab going, we're gonna make ketchup.
They did it, mission accomplished.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm a traditionalist, I like vinegar and salt.
Or just salt.
Well, now we're gonna try-
What is this one?
Honey mustard.
(audience laughs)
Bridget, thoughts.
I have to now,
I would say no potato chip is safe from me,
but I think that I wouldn't go after these.
(audience laughs)
I feel like even your dog might bark at that one.
My dog did leave two jars alone,
but she took down two, she took down the mustard
and she took down the rotisserie chicken.
Well then, fit for a queen or a king.
Yeah, a queen, I feel like those are the winners.
She happens to be allergic to chicken,
so I don't know if we're gonna have an issue a little later.
(laughs) I might have an issue alongside of her
after this taste test, so we'll see.
(upbeat bright music)